we've all seen a lot of anime characters
with amazing superpowers but there are
some anime that stand out for different
reasons including direction storyline
and character development when he add a
superhero aura that's mesmerizing into
the mix then we really can't stop
secretly wanting to have those powers so
here's a list of the top ten superpower
anime over this decade
at number 10 we have bungu stray dogs
the story revolves around Nakajima at
sushi who's kicked out of his orphanage
and now has no place to go while
starving on a riverbank at sushi saves
an eccentric man named Rosario desire
from drowning desire is a member of a
very special detective agency that deals
with crimes and incidents that other
authorities won't deal with they have
supernatural powers and deal with cases
that are too dangerous for the police or
military after inviting him to solve an
incident involving a rampant tiger in
the area which at sushi was skeptic and
agreeing to help supernatural powers get
revealed in him and they decide to
invite him to be a part of the agency
the tiger seems to have a connection to
at sushi and by the time the case is
solved it's clear that his future will
involve much more of desire in the rest
of the detectives
cook
good etiquette before consider
Corde darbuka
khan's order number nine is mob psycho
108th grader
Kageyama she gear has psychic abilities
and his nickname mob for lacking a sense
of presence although he looks
inconspicuous he is in fact a powerful
ESPA he could bend spoons and lift
objects with his mind from a young age
but as he grows older mob realizes that
his psychic powers are strengthening and
becoming more dangerous choosing to
suppress his power the only thing he
wants is to become friends with a girl
in his class named tsubomi to avoid his
power getting out of control he
constantly lives under an emotional
shackle to gain control of his skills
mob finds himself under the wing of a
rapper Corrigan a con artist who
exploits mobs powers mob wants to live a
normal life but the barrage of trouble
keeps coming after him with the
suppressed emotions growing inside mob
his power may break through his limits
fighter
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
at number eight it's seven deadly sins
the seven deadly sins were once an
active group of Knights in the region of
Britannia who disbanded after they
supposedly plotted to overthrow the
Leones Kingdom their defeat came at the
hands of the holy Knights but rumors
persist that these legendary Knights
called the seven deadly sins were still
alive ten years later the holy Knights
captured the king becoming the new
rulers of the kingdom nanatsu no taizai
follows the adventures of Elizabeth and
her search for the seven deadly sins
with their help she wants the kingdom
back and to find justice
not replacing her nanatsu thought I will
see maryadas
[Music]
at number 7 we have margeeve the story
set in an alternate recreation of the
ancient old world with several regions
and nations that resembled real-life
counterparts from that time there are
also several magic castles full of
treasures and traps known as dungeons
and each of them is the lair of a
powerful magic bead a Djinn individuals
that managed to overcome the trials of a
dungeon and earn the allegiance of its
Djinn are known as dungeon capturers
dungeons are said to be the work of
moggy a class of rare magicians who also
help people build their empires by
guiding them to a dungeon a boy called
Aladdin travels the world with his
friend Lugo a jinn that Aladdin can
summon with his flute he then meets
Alibaba Saluja a young man aiming to one
day explore the nearby dungeon amon and
claim its treasures Aladin and Alibaba
eventually become friends taking the
first step in an epic adventure that
will decide the fate of the world itself
do you know what was sure
[Music]
number six is my hero academia in a
world where people with superpowers
known as quirks are the norm is Zuko
midoriya has dreams of becoming a hero
despite not having a quirk from an early
age his only dream is to be a superhero
as he's always looked up to all might
the world's greatest hero after being
the only one to try and save his
childhood friend Kats key becau go from
a villain azúcar meets almighty who
bestows upon him his own quirk one for
all he chooses Zuko to be his successor
making him the ninth owner of the quark
one for all
he's initially very skinny but has
gained an array of well-developed
muscles after his 10 months of extensive
training with all might the story
follows a Zook whose entrance into you a
high school a prestigious high school
famous for cultivating the next
generation of superheroes as a zoo coup
and his new friends tried to balance
their hero training with ordinary school
duties they must face new challenges in
the looming threat of an evil
organization established by all mites
arch-nemesis
[Music]
look daughter Johnny Jimmy la oreja
she'd oh yeah dude I'm gonna die
at number five we have one punch man
this story revolves around Saitama who
chooses to be a hero as his hobby in a
world of super human beings Saitama is a
unique hero he's trained himself and
grown so strong that no enemy is able to
defeat him in battle
to the point that he can effortlessly
defeat any opponent with a single punch
now that it's become so easy he's bored
with his superhuman power and frustrated
at the complete lack of strong opponents
that can challenge him he displays a
laid-back attitude to everything for the
most part he finds his overall hero life
pointless then comes Janos a 19 year old
cyborg who wishes to be state Allah's
disciple say Tama joins the hero
Association in order to gain official
recognition with Janos and there begins
the adventures of one punch man an
ordinary yet extraordinary hero
an Imagineer
what stands out
yeah
[Music]
at number four its JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure this is one of the most
outrageous in joyas series you'll never
watch you owe it to yourself to
experience it JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
is the story of the Joestar family
starting with Jonathan the mild-mannered
Englishman who strikes up a rivalry with
Dio Brando his adopted brother because
of a cursed mask do becomes a powerful
vampire in Jonathan swears to stop him
after learning a fight we've called the
ripple which allows Jonathan to kill
vampires by punching the Sun into them
he goes on a quest to defeat do for good
how does this already weird concept get
weird at you ask well you're in for a
ride on the whole JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure is melodramatic and
action-packed you should definitely give
yourself the gift of seeing it yourself
[Music]
at number three we have attack on Titan
2,000 years from now mankind was nearly
exterminated by tall monstrous humanoid
creatures called Titans humans survived
by walling themselves in a city
protected by extremely high walls even
taller than the biggest of titans these
giants killed humans for pleasure not
out of hunger they instinctively attack
any humans on site to ensure their
survival humans lived within defensive
barriers in Hana Sina Titan in over 100
years
teenager Aaron and his sister Mikasa
witnessed something horrific as the city
walls are destroyed by a colossal Titan
reigniting the fight for survival
against the man-eating abominations
after witnessing this Eren joins the
brutal war against the Titans and vows
that he will murder every single Titan
and take revenge for all of mankind
Jonathan also higher token caucus we do
mother I don't I are the most cynical
neo-nazi colony
[Music]
number two is fate/zero the Holy Grail
war is a contest founded by the Ines
Bern matau and two Sacco families
centuries ago in which seven mages
summons seven heroic spirits to compete
to obtain the power of the Holy Grail
which grants a wish to each member of
the winning duo with the promise of
granting any wish the omnipotent Holy
Grail triggered three wars in the past
each two cruel and fierce to leave a
victor faint zero is the story of the
fourth Holy Grail war the much hated
Mongoose killer cured subbu amia a man
whose sterner and more merciless than
anyone else is hired by the irons burns
now kiyotsugu faces off against six
other participants each fueled by unique
desires and ideals carried sugu finds
his greatest opponent incur a courtroom
in a a priest who's trying to discover
his true nature in his quest to find the
Holy Grail
[Music]
and finally at number one we have hunter
hunter gone leaves his home on Whale
Island determined to become the best
hunter possible in the hopes of finding
his father who was a hunter himself and
had long ago abandoned his young son to
become a hunter he must pass the hunter
examination where he meets and befriends
three other applicants guru Becca Lee
Oreo and Kahlua the four of them take
the hunter exam notorious for its low
success rate in high probability of
death throughout their journey gone and
his friends faced a lot of hardships and
confront many monsters and creatures in
the process they learn what being a
hunter truly means can these four pass
this formidable hurdle to become the
best hunter in the world and will gone
eventually meet his father well watch
the anime and you might just find out so
what do you guys think of this list if
there are any particular videos that you
wants us to create then comment below
and let us know and of course leave a
like if you've enjoyed the video feel
free to subscribe if you haven't and hit
the notification button so you never
miss our new uploads we'll see you next
time on video tube goodbye
[Music]
[Music]